hey there boys and girls it's your old
podcast pal Ralph here why don't you
check out the Ralph report that's my
Daily Show Monday through Friday you can
get an ear full of me and we have a
pretty good time plus if you're a
Hollywood Babylon fan and you subscribe
at the three or four star general levels
you can get the entire back catalog of
Hollywood Babylon the past decade of
babylon's for you to listen to at your
leisure plus the four star tier they get
to watch us record the show live once a
week plus there's a live stream events
all kinds of goodies why don't you go
check it out we're over there at patreon
go to patreon.com the route report
that's
p-a-t-r-e-o-n.com slash the Ralph report
or check us out at the ralphreport.com
it's me Kevin Smith Jason mules have you
ever wanted to get lost on the high seas
with Jay and Silent Bob well now you're
gonna have your chance go to Jay and
Silent Bob
cruisesque.com right now and sign up for
Jay and Silent Bob's Cruise Escape what
are you waiting for man get lost at sea
with Jay and Silent bone let's do it
it's time to babble the [__] on
[Music]
this Hollywood Babylon
with your hosts Kevin Smith and Ralph
Garman
[Music]
it is Saturday night
burback Jesus
can't even blame it on weed anymore it's
Saturday night in burbanks let's battle
the [__] out I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph
Garner
hi gang
nice to be back kids full admission man
on Tuesday I'll be 12 weeks Weed Free
don't [__] applaud that
oh my God getting old is so terrible a
few years ago I [__] went vegan used
to be happy now I'm [__] vegan right
and uh [__] man it used to be [__]
stoned and now I'm what they call
mindful so this is my new [__] this
is my new uh [__] this is this is what
keeps me calm that's a bottle of
lavender
so throughout the show I'll periodically
like
oh my God that's called poppers Kevin is
that what it is
this [__] smells no no no why it'll make
I have a I have a strong aversion to
Lavender
are you serious yeah like a strong
aversion it's what it's one of my least
favorite touched you with lavender I
don't know
uh I really have a strong aversion to
Lavender are you doing a bit no no no
it's serious as [__] well I [__] need
this
to keep me at Bay yes no to keep me
[__] calm yeah
leave it over here God you don't like
this I would suck dick for this [__] oh
my God I put it all over my bed and [__]
I put it all over my dogs no
oh yeah exactly
no there's a few smells in life that I
cannot abide and that's one of them
[__] lavender no [__] I'm all about
that they have a bottle of [__] in your
pocket I'll take that that's what
Lavender is it's nature no it's not
no it's Nature's herpes I've known you
like
I've known you 15 20 years at this point
and lavender never came up I know what
are the odds what are your other [__]
Kryptonite smells
um that's the worst one I'm not a big
fan of uh anything like sickly sweet
like uh like candy cotton candy bubble
gum some stuff like that oh my God
you're so bitter
it's just a trigger I don't know why
what do you like steak a [__] like to
smell a steak and [__] yeah human blood
so there's somebody like a gorgeous
woman and [__] and she smells like
lavender and you'd be like get off me uh
hmm how hot
gorgeous
um after I'd be like get off man when
it's all done yeah it's all over here
that's the way you are normally without
the lavender as well how have you been
good keep this far away man fine I have
no idea yeah
that's so like hold on a second
seriously that's so get over it man I
don't feel like I want to go backstage
and have a conversation then restart the
show put the lavender away yeah it's
just uh it's something about it I was
literally gonna put it on my ears dab it
like here like a lady and [__] but now
I'm glad I didn't because he's like we
won't be making out later I guess not
[__] man uh yeah I gave up weed uh which
is like I'll tell you worst time in the
in my life to give up weed because
remember I bought a movie theater right
right which you'd imagine would be fun
but can I tell you something about film
exhibition nobody's going to the movies
anymore man yeah uh Avatar Two opening
night 12 people
I know I don't know where the [__] it
made money not at my theater and [__] uh
Creed 3 opening night seven o'clock
Friday night show six [__] people no
[__] Shazam whole audience said
shazot and didn't [__] show up
so you know what does well there
yes Kevin Smith Kevin Smith movies we
did a clerks Marathon like uh we did
clerks open all night we showed clerks
clerks too and clerks three from
midnight till six sold the [__] out a
week from tonight I'll be back in Jersey
doing a Chasing Amy show with Jason Lee
that's [__] sold out and stuff
um but other than my [__]
kids movies the railings oh this [__]
I'm you know who's dick I'm ready to
suck is Super Mario holy [__] he
single-handedly saved my [__] theater
and [__] we should call ourselves a
super super battle brothers or something
trying to get a little uh little bounce
off you wear a redhead I'll wear a green
hat we'll mark it off that we'll do
really insulting Italian accents or
we'll just sound like Chris Pratt
um we we show like [__] we don't not
even new kids movies we showed the
[__] Muppet movie and we had 170
people that night well if you're got if
you got kids yes you want to get them
out of the house and you want to get out
of the house with them why because you
want to keep them calm you know it'll
keep a kid calm no get the [__] away you
just put
just put a kid I'll be like no if
they're bouncing off the walls at the
house you're like okay let's the [__]
car and go someplace and do something
the movies is a great great option we've
noticed that people like drop their kids
off in the liquor take the [__] off they
slow down and just open the door and
roll them out the car and [__] it's
Jersey so they're tough
speaking of Muppets yes you didn't tell
me you were cheating on me
oh [__]
yeah here I thought we were the band I
thought we got Dr Josh Roush back
tonight by the way yeah
so the band is truly back together and
then I see you whoring around with
another band can we put that picture up
of Kevin Smith
and that other band
it's been a minute Josh I know you're
you're still getting your sea legs there
we go
look at that you with the Mayhem that
was back when I was a stoner look how
happy I am
I'm like puppets
um yeah that was July man uh before yeah
it was way back uh I had that picture on
my phone for so long and I always wanted
to post it on Instagram but they're like
don't until the [__] show is coming
up so they dropped the trailer for uh
The Muppets uh Mayhem it's called it's a
Disney plus series I think it starts in
May yeah and uh so once I saw that the
trailer went up and I was in the trailer
I was like oh [__] and I put that up on
my Instagram most likes I've had like
[__] all year and [__] everyone loves
a goddamn Muppet I'll tell you that much
can't go wrong it was you know honestly
like all kidding aside like I've been uh
let me see March we just got into April
March it was 30 years ago in March that
we started shooting clerks wow so this
January it'll be 30 years that I'm in
the entertainment business right so in
30 years I thank you very much
now I'm crisp enough to hear that
um it'll be 30 years that I've been like
in entertainment and [__] and at a
certain point you've like seen it all
and and you know how the sausage is made
and I've met famous people and whatnot
and done very cool things but being on
set with Muppets was like transcended it
was absolutely magical
um the whole set is built in a way where
like you're standing on one level and
then everything has holes in the floor
where I don't know if you know this or
not but [__] Muppets are operated by
people what the [__] spoilers
if you were stoned that would blow your
mind right well I was stoned and I was
like what
they had to keep pulling me away from
the edge because I get so close I had
almost fallen but uh the muppeteers are
down below like on the actual floor and
all the sets are raised right so that
when they go like this and they
literally say Muppets up and up go the
[__] Muppets and [__] they're on your
level or at least at least near your
level
so you can be standing there and I was
talking to a muppeteer and they'll
they're talking to you with their voice
and [__] but they keep the Muppet alive
no yeah they're never like [__] like
it's never down or [__] sitting off
to the side or something like that they
have them up so even when they're
talking to you they're doing this [__]
and blinking and nodding so it's almost
like you're having a conversation with
three people and [__] and then when they
address you through the Muppet you can't
even though the the Muppet here is
standing right there I'd be like you do
your hand okay so I'm here so and start
doing them up hi ho everybody it's good
to see you here today yeah you just
[__] stare at the Muppet like it's a
real life voices if you're not doing a
muppet so anyway Kevin when we get going
again we're going out of my way like you
just all you want to do is look into the
eyes of the [__] the velvety eyes of
the Muppets it was absolutely [__]
beautiful one of the most fun times I've
ever had like doing anything anywhere
and the trailer looks very fun it does
look good Adam Goldberg who does the
Goldbergs uh he invited me into it
because he was the one that did the show
is a huge Muppet fan and uh he was very
kind he sent me a clip of the show One
Night in the middle of night I got a
text and I open up my phone and it was
like my whole first scene he just shot
it like off the editing bag oh fun and
it's [__] dope I want to spoil it but
then they'll cut me out yeah but I hear
don't
God damn it I interact with animal
quite a bit
[Applause]
he took Jay's place
and May in the future I'm guessing Okay
I was like you better [__] shape up
man because I got a new buddy
and he's way more wild than you uh it
was absolutely [__] delightful though
like truly I've said it before it's
gonna sound tired but very magical like
just took all my 30 years of like I've
seen it all in this business right away
reduced me to being a child I I used to
watch The Muppets like every night with
my grandmother because it was a
syndicated program yeah right so beyond
like five nights a week and stuff and
she loved the Muppets I love the Muppets
so then I was on set I was literally
telling Dr Teeth I was like I used to
watch you
with my grandmother the muppeteer was
like I'm right here buddy but they gotta
Get Behind The Muppets so you make human
human eye contact but yeah it'll be
it'll be good man the show looks very
very funny and stuff that's awesome yeah
hey guys thanks for closing closing us
out thanks for selling us out tonight
guys we appreciate it yes
yes thank you so much uh we have a
little business to take care of we have
another show here again next month on
the 20th of May we'll be back yeah buy
tickets right now we'll wait yeah
phones aren't coming out at all
and then the following month in June
we're going to be performing at your
same said movie theater in uh in New
Jersey we're going to be in Hollywood
Babylon there in June Hollywood Babylon
going back to New Jersey man we're doing
it at smodcast Castle Cinemas you get
tickets right now they're on sale at
smog
castlecinemas.com the uh we June no
fifth is it June June yeah June 3rd
thank you somebody said June 3rd June
3rd and then June 4th we're also doing
Hollywood Babylon Comic-Con Theater
which we haven't done in a million years
that's where we read comics and we pull
people on stage and let them read and
[__] like that I guarantee you we
outcross The Flash
that actually people show up for I'm
gonna go see that movie I think I was
talking about last time I get to go to
cinemacon uh in in a week or two I guess
it's not this week but the week after
um Josh too Josh owns a piece of this
mod Castle cinemas as well oh so we get
to go as exhibitors and [__] and see
flash they're running it on April 25th
which is actually like my anniversary my
24th anniversary and my wife's like what
are we doing for our 24th anniversary I
was like we're seeing the [__] flash
[__] I don't know what you're doing
I'll tell you where I'm gonna be uh and
if you want to be there fine but yeah
man I I cannot wait man have you seen
the new piece like the the new like
there's a trailer that's dropping April
25th so they keep dropping these little
teasers on TV and one of them showed
Michael Keaton in bat suit with a cow
cow off oh my God yeah that's my happy
place right there man [__] Michael
Keaton Batman I saw some people bitching
online about like the CG and I was like
I don't care if they do it with [__]
puppets preferably Muppets like Michael
Keaton as Batman [__] oh my God I'm
so therefore yeah for sure
um we're also once again I think you
know covid kicked the ass of Hollywood
Babylon because it's a live show and we
couldn't do it for about two years
because of covid and everyone
quarantining and staying safe so it's
been a minute since we've gotten things
back up to speed and we're going to do
it monthly at least moving forward the
best that we can but I know actually
we're back now yeah because someone
reached out and said they wanted to
sponsor Hollywood Babble on tonight we
got an ad we have an ad I'm very excited
I mean technically we just did one for
the Muppets for like I know for no money
yes
but satisfaction but the folks at
manscaped.com
yeah because as you know I'm a big
manscaper we've talked about it on the
show you have to with those nuts of
years that's right Ralph has the biggest
dangliest balls man I have voluminous
balls yeah no dick [__] a lot of
people how dare you sir no meat all
veggies the rod matches the tackle I'll
have you know
they're reaching out to us because it's
tax season and people are going to be
getting uh tax refunds so what better
way to spend your money than on your
friends and your family and ball
deodorant I think that's this
I was trying to make the connection I
was like what does tax season have to do
they're like I lost all my money might
as well shave my nuts if you get a tax
refund you gotta invest it in yourself
so we're doing uh tonight is sponsored
by manscaped and they send a bunch of
stuff so I'm gonna give this [__] away
to some people because I've already got
some
um manscape is that I mean I'm just
saying this because it gave us money to
do an ad but like they they have a nose
hair trimmer which I use all the [__]
time you know about it or are you just
applauding nose hair trimming
it's the best nose hair trimmer in the
world
yes and also side note it vibrates so if
you hold it against your dick you'll
come
I just [__] heard
I think I read it on the website this
one's not charged this is not charged I
think they're I think the [__] if I'm
not gonna come that way I need my
lavender
and this is the razor the razors came
charged originally man I'm gonna give
this away slightly used I hope no one
Minds
originally they were all about like
shave your nuts but now they have a full
line it's like they got shampoo and
stuff like that body wash shampoo
deodorant uh they've got the B the beard
hedger so they have you covered for your
whole body from top to bottom well I
think that's because people were using
the ball trimmer to shave their beards
and they're like hold on we'll give you
an actual here's a separate thing yeah
uh this here that I have this is the
performance pack 4.0 and it's got
everything that we were talking about
it's got the nose hair and ear hair
clipper it's got the Razor for your
balls all this stuff is waterproof too
so you can use in the shower because
that's where I like to manscape this is
the toner that is crop reviver it's
called crop reviver it's your ball toner
because you don't want you don't want
untoned balls no no and this is the crop
preserver yeah to make your uh nuts ball
deodorant ball deodorant and um it makes
them stick free so they don't stick you
should smell it make sure it's okay with
you it is I've I've used all these
products already so I know that the
scent is excellent no lavender involved
lavender free performance package 4. 2.0
the lawnmower trimmer comes in this the
uh the ear and nose trimmer as we talked
about the crop preserver the crop
reviver all can be yours if you go to
manscaped.com and you get 20 off and
free shipping just by using the code
Babble when do you check out how about
that it's making me [__] not calm no
stop
and the beard hedger too uh is also
available all this good stuff can be
yours at manscape.com 20 off free
shipping if you use the code Babble so
go there and support the kind people who
reach out please support them because
Heavens they're supporting us they are
indeed you get a beard don't you sir
yeah here here's the beard trimmer
that's for you right there
I'm only saying it because you look like
you could use a little trim quite
frankly but
I thought you're talking I'm being
helpful don't groan he'll Thank Me Later
aren't you glad you got here early and
set up front and [__]
would you like some lavender as well no
lavender
anybody have uh smelly balls yeah
[Applause]
this young lady is Raising her hand over
there
she's drinking the Bud Light that's how
I know what she's uh
wow finger on the pulse well done man
thank you so much [__] yeah
I'm not new
wife
oh my God that was impressive
so that's like that's like radio good
that's like you were [__] back on
K-Rock and had to be on top of [__] back
when I was good
when we was fabbed yes
oh [__] me
I'm happier now yeah [__] yeah you are
let's get to the show what do you say
are we gonna give away the wrestlers
well you know we got some shout outs so
I thought maybe we'd give it them out to
people who are here tonight from
particularly long distances or
celebrating special occasions I gotta
tell you it's like you planned the whole
show without me isn't it isn't it like
that isn't it just like that
[__] you
it's almost as if I put the whole show
together to take a couple days to build
it and then you roll in and sit down for
about an hour with me it's almost like
that literally one of my favorite things
about this show is I comment it just
happens but for you it seems to be like
something you work on in advance
it's you working me
oh
let's say let's say in folks who have
done all the things I said just earlier
it's called the shout out
it's a shout out we're camping around so
get your cows
yes indeed apparently didn't need weed
for that no
you can blow a mic Stone Cold Sober
that's true what's my excuse now though
back in the day I used to be like well
that was high
now that I'm thinking about it
you you're snorting more than I did back
in the good old days my shit's cheaper
than your [__] is that's for sure uh
Angus Sinclair are you here tonight
Angus
g'day Angus
[Music]
how do you know Angus
did you meet him in line
yeah I bet you did
Angus writes a g'day Ralph and Kevin
he's from Australia
[__] what part
did you bring something for me to sign
yeah a Funko Pop
my friend Joaquin told me about you he's
like there's a guy here who [__] came
from Australia to see you he's going who
the [__] are you
and Ralph yeah and whatever
[Music]
did you bring Ralph's pop no so [__]
uh
[Laughter]
throw that [__] up here man or you can
walk it up walk it on up man I'll read
his email while he wants stuff here
coming to your show on April 15th all
the way from Melbourne Australia now
Melbourne is that different than
Melbourne
it is Melbourne why does he sell
Melbourne because he's making fun of
Americans is that why you [__]
turn around walk back to your seat you
come on up Mel
uh bringing my wife who hasn't seen the
show before so it should be good fun I
believe you're going to want to be
confused as hell or I'll just stay here
or let's all [__] sell this
special edition man
um who should I put it to anyone or just
tag it Angus
a-n-g-u-s okay
anus with a G is in the middle
you're right it is yeah it is now that I
see it written out now that you're sober
you're seeing everything more clearly
really man I'm so crisp this is a really
nice Sharpie Angus well done anger says
I would love to see you two do a Shoei
with whatever you're drinking tonight
what's a chewy yeah see that's why we're
not gonna do it you [__] animal
you know what a Shoei is no it's this
Australian thing where you take your
drink and you take your shoe off then
you pour it into your shoe and then you
drink it out of your shoe
disgusting we know
yeah you can drink beer but I'm not
going to ruin good Jack Daniels by
putting it in my shoe I'll tell you that
much we could do it and then afterwards
no we're not smelling your [__]
lavender all right Angus and your lovely
wife what's your name
Jen thank you Jess Jess thank you so
much for coming all this way we
appreciate it thank you
thanks for making the trip
we have so many uh HBO fans down in in
Australia we really have to get there
someday
I said the guy who [__] came all the
way here carrying the pop they let you
bring that on the plane and [__]
you bought a business class seat for us
it's like your service animal
uh Patrick grun grundly
am I saying that correct Patrick
yeah sure
Patrick came all the way from Norway
are you [__] kidding me yeah did you
bring a pop as well
uh he brought a book didn't you bring a
book you want Kevin to sign bring it on
up we're signing all kinds of [__]
tonight apparently
foreign
Patrick says it was a long plane ride
from Norway did you know that holding in
a fart for over 10 hours can hurt your
sphincter I didn't know that that is why
did you hold it in
because he's from Norway and they're
polite oh how are you man welcome what
part of Norway as if I know any parts
right in the middle yeah
that's a Swinton right isn't that right
there in the near is it there Swinton
is it spell Patrick spelled the normal
weather no there's
p-a-t-r-i-i-k okay that ain't the normal
way no it is in Norway I bet I guess so
do I put an umlaut over it or whatever
no but his last name Gruden grundly has
a in there it's got the horns
yeah the Ghostbusters though
why do you [__] have to be so
different and have to put a line through
your oh just use the [__] o
nobody cares
oh look at this we put a lane through
the air so everybody thinks we're
special
if he's unnerving you smell this
yes right
such a pleasure There You Go sir
the next person better be from another
[__] country if they're from America
[__] them yeah I'm spoiled now right
uh I want to go to Scandinavia to that
part of the world I wanna that's one of
my bucket list things I want to see
Finland and Norway and Sweden I'm going
to spend some time there is Patrick do
you vouch for for that part of the world
some like real friction going is that
right yeah they don't like it
what'd they do to you pork pork pork
the Finns are the happiest people in the
world
is that right it's absolutely
scientifically proven that people in
Finland have the highest rate of
Happiness of everyone on the planet
um and yet I think with the winter war
is that what it's called the Finn's like
years years ago when they fought the
Germans uh yeah then the Russians like
they were like [__] vicious yes and
they the Russians and the and the
Germans [__] off because they were
just yeah and that's what made them
happy yes
we beat the Nazis
is that does that is that close or no
he went like this
Kevin you know by now nothing is close
it's true but hopefully it's a man of
nine voices that's right uh Chris Duffy
are you here Chris
where are you here's Chris right there
where are you from
Alaska that's another [__] country
might as well be
Chris drove
from Alaska can you do that
I guess so you just have to come through
you have to go through Russia I think
but still you can get here you gotta cut
through Canada right to get here
yeah it's not like Hawaii you can't
drive here from Hawaii I understand but
like Alaska
you could definitely make it really
never was the Pod was it no no
[__] you
welcome to the lower 48 my friend as we
say very rarely uh Chris is a retired
Air Force uh
well
sadly one of the reasons he drove down
was because his mom passed away in
Delaware so he drove down to be with her
and then he decided since he was in the
lower 48 he would come by and uh see us
so I appreciate that he says here I
brought a 12 pack of yinglings for you
[Music]
in the car yeah I've heard that before
you're gonna come out to the car I got
yinglings for you
[Laughter]
where are my yinglings
he's like
my England's are in your stomach now
[Laughter]
that's funny is that a beer that you can
only get in Alaska or no no it's a
Philly it's a Pennsylvania beer it's my
it's my beloved Pennsylvania I remember
but yes but you can only get it uh east
of the Rockies or the Mississippi or
some [__] so he was in Delaware so I'm
assuming he got some is that where you
went to Delaware that's where his mom
was
I'm so sorry
you went to the odds of Mark show
[__] a man right on well [__] good
seeing you so you're stalking Kevin now
I guess that's what's happening that's
okay he brought you the England yeah I
know so he says in the car
uh Celeste Soriano are you here Celeste
o
she didn't want to commit because she's
not from [__] Norway or Australia
she's from Upland oh [__] that's almost
like another country as well
statistically uplanders are the happiest
people on Earth that's because they beat
the Russians and the Germans they
knocked them out of California
my name is Celeste I'm a long time
Lister my partner Jose is with me
tonight for our first Hollywood Babylon
we'll welcome you welcome
your first time
if at any time you feel nervous or
whatnot take a snort right up your
nostrils man
done and done a dab will do you he has
no idea what's going on you've never
heard the show before Jose what are your
thoughts so far
[__] hey man after this yeah really
uh could Bane give him a warm welcome
and a short description of what he'll be
getting himself into tonight I think I
can man I think you can too
Jose
you're in for a pleasant evening at the
Hollywood Babylon one of us is very calm
and the other is a [__] when it comes
to Lavender
dick
I have one question for you do you have
any weed no no you're you're not doing
that it's not for me it's for a friend
I'll be ready for good times this guy's
funny and this guy's just present
how long have you been with this last
how long have you gotten the third base
you have
can we see
[Laughter]
oh say you look like a hairy dude are
you like a you're like a bear are you
like one of those Bears they talk about
Celeste is he Harry
on the face power's balls
they're hairy right now well we got just
the thing to take care of that my friend
come on up here
for your first Hollywood Babylon
experience we're gonna give him the uh
the set the whole [__] came from
Norway and you're like here Upland
come on up grab it before we give it to
a foreigner you signed some [__] for
them
we can get the guy from Norway deodorant
If he if he you know I want some
deodorant
he got right the [__] up man look at him
it's a long flight back to Norway you
probably can use it here hold on nice
hands
what about Alaska Alaska let's see what
we got left here uh we have a shampoo
and conditioner combined or shaved head
don't give him the shampoo
how about some body wash body wash body
wash in Alaska
yeah all right sure I'm not gonna throw
this because this could kill someone
this is heavy it's in a metal bottle
it's a metal bottle but we could pass it
back all right can we pass this back to
Alaska right there
there you go Chris what about Australia
you got a hard one for Australia right
now I think he's with his wife lady why
don't you just calm down for a second
uh um shampoo and conditioner Australia
what do you say
you can watch Jess's hair at the hotel
later on tonight it's very erotic hand
that back to him all right all the
manscape.com stuff is gone
[Music]
and lastly I bring these guys up and
actually it's not lastly it's the
penultimate you know oh [__]
um Shannon and Patrick Finn were
supposed to be here at our last show
they're right up front I should have
given you the [__] beer yeah
they were the ones who were driving from
Reno and if you remember it was like
horrific snow and rain bad weather and
we they sent in a shout out expecting to
be here the last show and we talked
about them and they weren't here and we
decided they were dead remember yes they
were they'd eaten each other yeah they
resorted to cannibalism well it worked
because they've eaten people and they're
actually here tonight so thank you so
much way to survive Shannon and Patrick
Finn from Reno Nevada Nevada
Nevada right yeah I get in so much
trouble with that people are getting
very sweet we did a show in Reno didn't
we or Tahoe where which was
the 100th show was in Reno I remember
that and I'm [__] the baked one you
don't remember you're looking at me all
blank I have no remember of ever memory
of ever performing in our 100th show we
did in Reno that's Nevada that's a lot
of shows to go son yeah
um I I understand you have a gift for us
is that what I mean
now this is I want to see this
yes
pull these tabs oh my god did you get me
an ad at
this reminds me of being 11 years old at
Christmas thank you so much oh look at
that bag the bag alone is a treat look
at that 60s Batman that's awfully small
compared to this yeah I know
I hear it pull the box from that side
kids
this is Liam Neeson's [__]
one sixth scale it's the one sixth scale
Liam Neeson's [__]
oh my God it's like a muppet
all right
[Laughter]
well now we've got a fourth on the show
me you Josh and this yeah there you go
this is amazing did you make this
that's incredible
uh it's a manscape and it's manscaped
yes this is a body pillow I'm totally
sleeping she also made me a Batman [__]
and balls
oh that rocks it's a bad [__]
look how [__] huge it is
stop stroking it you're weirding me out
I'm gonna move my cup and put it right
here
Jesus you just hit that lady in the face
with your [__]
that'll be the absolute first time
should is it blocking anyone's views
yeah
mine I'm sorry is my dick blocking you
let's put it between us no let's not do
that
[Music]
yeah we can go ass to ask
[Laughter]
look at the way she sewed it there's
like a head on yeah man
it's like you've seen one before
because it's kind of what it looks like
except way smaller and it's uncut so it
is like Liam Neeson
I'm totally sleeping with this tonight
like a body pillow and my wife's gonna
be like you should go back on the pot
yeah I was like this is my new lavender
it keeps me calm a fast G Magnus it's me
Kevin Smith Jason have you ever wanted
to get lost on the high seas with Jay
and Silent Bob well now you're gonna
have your chance go to Jay and Silent
Bob
cruisesque.com right now and sign up for
Jay and Silent Bob's Cruise Askew we're
gonna hit the high seas where we going
Gilligan we're gonna be going to Miami
to Nassau Bahamas and into Norwegian
Pearl doesn't that sound great it's
gonna be me and him it's gonna be all of
our friends we'll be doing live podcasts
there's going to be a movies on board
there's gonna be a viewer skew Museum
great times to be had by all ladies and
gentlemen tickets available right now go
buy a man and if you sign up before June
23rd it's only 100 down per cabin what
are you waiting for man get lost at sea
with Jay and Silent
let's do it
and lastly Nick and Amy are here Nick
and Amy Gregory where are you guys hi
guys also from Australia moved here from
Australia to La eight years ago [__]
hey Nick works in the industry you work
in animation Nick is that right
yeah you used to work for Marvel Studios
you used to give that gig up oh you're
inside why did you give it up better gig
do you need some lavender
anyway when he's not working for the man
he's working for himself and he sent in
this beautiful painting that I wanted to
show everyone this apparently hangs in
his office take a look at this Kevin I
think you'll get a kick out of this holy
[__] [__] this is a gorgeous painting
that he's done with characters from many
of your films that is legit [__]
wonderful and it's got obscure [__]
uh Zack and Miri characters yeah I mean
I'm nor used to seeing Jay and Bob and
you got the two Devils as opposed to the
and there's [__] Bartleby and Loki
who's between them up top
Lester the Molester from [__] Zach
and Mary and there's the Jay angel with
God and there's the there's Rufus Jesus
this is can I buy this off you
Maybe
done that is [__] fantastic man you
got a nice style did you want Kevin to
sign that for you too is that what I
heard your wife brought it I think
tonight didn't she yeah she brought it
you snuck it in he didn't know this is a
surprise for Nick come on up and Kevin
will uh tag that for you bring it up
Kevin will keep it for you yeah
you may have to make a copy
God it's [__] tremendous and you just
did it for the love of doing it
[__] man excellent to meet you
all right let's try to make it beautiful
anyways oh you got Jay to sign it
already
he did a show here
keep up with your friends at all do you
yeah
um should I just sign it or should I
personalize it
and I see nobody spells their name
normal anymore what the [__]
n-i-c-k dude it's right there God this
is [__] gorgeous man it is a nice
piece no characters from yoga hosers
I've noticed but that's fine it's all
right you got excellent [__] uh
excellent style and there's the van with
the Buddy Christ in it [__] man I saw
that movies can banky's pest control or
house rats and Mall Rats so nice thank
you Nick and pleasure
making dreams come true here on the
Hollywood Babylon show
we also get email
Commons got an email man
featuring Kevin's reactions that's right
Elite Alice not Elise at all Alice
Delgado writes
[Laughter]
um try it try hugging it I'm not
interested thank you why don't be such a
hard ass I'm not just it's just you know
yes [__] yes doesn't that feel good it
does feel good yeah
yeah
I knew you were in a swallow you got a
pube
[Music]
um can you guys thank you guys for
getting me through my work as a clerk
every day I listen during the dead hours
which I can imagine is all the time
thank you Alice can you call my
boyfriend and ass when he chose to pull
a Dante and have an affair with his ex
who cheated on him in the past as the
voice of Al Pacino
it's very specific very specific I love
cursing to people especially as Al
Pacino hold on man let me shoot this we
haven't heard house theme in a while can
I hear Al's theme
come on now come on Margaritas
[Music]
come on now come on Margaritas oh
Alice's boyfriend
what a [__]
how dare you cheat on the beautiful
Alice Delgado you're out there eating
Del Taco and you got Delgado at home
mwah
she's got a great ass
and you are one son
Alice kick him to the curb girlfriend
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know what you are
a big dick
there you go props I like it nice well
done
uh speaking of Kevin's work Michael
Beaver sent in this picture he took
while out on the road he said I hope
kev's getting a piece of this this was a
Jeep he saw on the road by the way and
oh [__]
you getting anything from the Buddy
Jesus wheel covers not from that one no
it looks like a that looks kind of
homemade like an Etsy thing yeah but I
don't own Jesus so at the end of the day
I tried I tried to trademark Jesus
they're like you know you can't do that
right really yeah yeah
you don't belong to me because he
belongs to all of us yes he does he is
risen just like this
beat me to it and lastly Chuck Hirsch
writes in in honor of a [__] strong
name chucker Chuck Hirsch private eye
yes
in honor of recent events could you sing
they're coming to take me away as Donald
Trump
[Applause]
I don't even know what he's referring to
in terms of recent events but uh I
haven't dusted off my Donald for a while
this should be fun can we get a little
music there Josh
remember when you ran away and I get on
my knees and begged you not to leave
because I'd go berserk
well you left me anyhow and then the
days got worse and worse and now you see
I've gone completely out of my mind
and they're coming to take me away okay
they're coming to take me away to the
funny farm where Life is Beautiful all
the time and I'll be happy to see those
nice young men in their polo shirts and
khakis and they're coming to take me
away
[Music]
all right there you go
folks send us emails with towns that
they've discovered that have [__] up
names that we never bothered to name
this segment so we call it your Town's
got a [__] up name
[Music]
Pablo Hernandez writes while searching
for directions to visit a friend in
Boise Idaho I noticed this town on the
map he sent us a little piece of the map
to show us
big shooter
we got one of those right here yeah we
do
dick shooter Idaho is the name of the
town and they're aware that their name
is ridiculous they've leaned into it I
found a website that has all the dick
shooter merchandise also sounds like a
private eye show dick shooter private
eye get this for the kids well next time
you're out looking for something
happens is appropriate for children like
the dick shooter t-shirts for the kids
where do you think kids come from that's
true
folks also send us emails featuring
stuff meant for kids like the dick
shooter t-shirts supposed to be
enjoyable for children toys and the like
and it turns out when we look at them
they are inappropriate
[Music]
James zionozzi sent this sin this is
from a supermarket chain in the UK
called Aldi
and Easter of course just passed they
were selling marshmallow Easter bunnies
and chicks for the kids do they not have
all the out here
it's we have Aldi in Burbank you made it
sound like oh it's a foreign
okay let me start again there's a chain
in Germany and England and America
called Aldi Supermarkets and they were
selling um marshmallow like peeps but
shaped like bunnies and chicks at least
that's what the package says one mother
bought them for her kids and then she
noticed no [__]
can we punch in on those uh peeps there
yeah
those are marshmallow [__] and balls
more than a mouthful
and I love that Aldi in response on
Twitter put this up
we can't even defend this one
you rarely see that from a business just
copying to it's like [__] you got us
we're busted those are indeed
marshmallow [__] I don't know how it
happens it's just
eat up kids
uh Todd in Renton Washington sent this
in are you familiar with this toy it's
called Bop It
it's a it's like a puzzle toy for kids
this is from a Mandalorian obviously
with the child and Todd said he was
playing with it and the sounds well it
sounds like the Mandalorian and the
child have a different kind of
relationship than they do in the series
can we show someone playing that please
Josh
oh
stop it
it's just the Mandalorian saying bop it
and pull it over and over and over again
sounds like something's going on in the
cab of the spaceship
and lastly Kevin Conroy sent this in
sadly not that Kevin Conroy uh our Kevin
comrade our Kevin Conrad yeah this is
from an amusement park in Southwest
Germany that got in trouble because of
their recent ride
I saw a picture of it I don't see it but
I got some video but I haven't looked at
it maybe it'll clarify things uh kids
and they don't like kids in Germany
riding this ride for some reason it's
called the eagle fly let's take a look
good the planes like you're riding in
Planes oh wait a minute
okay now I see it now maybe
maybe the Giants spinning swastikas
are necessarily the best ride for kids
in Germany I just
beat Germany home of that foreign food
store Aldi
the owner of the Tasmania amusement park
which is the name of that rudiger Braun
said yeah yeah now I can see that the
Platinum man would be we're fixing it
there'll be three eagles instead of four
eagles flying around so it won't be so
much problems
nine nine problems
just for the children's
every episode we have to say goodbye to
some folks in Show Business who left us
soon too soon but left behind bodies of
work that will last forever we call
those the Tinseltown stiffs and now
another edition of
[Music]
[Applause]
they will be missed who died uh like me
I'm sure you grew up worshiping Mad
Magazine yes oh I know remember the fold
in covers of Mad Magazine Al Jaffe Al
Jackson great Al Jaffe comic genius and
amazing artist has passed away this week
at the age of 102. he met he went deep
though he did go deep Mad Magazine had
those uh fold-in covers for 55 years and
he was the only artist to draw them and
in their entire history yeah if you've
never seen one here's a little video of
what it looked like it would be a funny
picture
and then it would have a little uh a
little blurb on it like what is
constantly reaching record Heights and
then you would fold the cover in and it
would turn out to be sneaker prices or
something like that it was always sort
of a surprise and you couldn't read man
magazine and not fold it in you had to
do it it was compulsive you saved it for
the end it was the very back page and it
was the last uh you know there's usually
a joke ad on the back but the full then
was a big it gave you a workout
did you know because there's a physical
activity uh he was also responsible for
snappy answers to stupid questions that
was another segment of his so a man who
shaped a lot of our senses of humor for
many years really did honestly like I
part of what I do comes from reading MAD
magazine growing up and he was a big
[__] part of that but a hundred and
two it's not a bad run yeah that's
that's pretty damn incredible and he was
working almost up until the end yeah
yeah I think they stopped making the
magazine in 2019 I think I'd be still
working with it until at least 2016.
yeah one of my favorite character actors
Michael Lerner has passed away at the
age of 81. uh this guy was in every TV
show in the 70s and 80s then he started
really hitting large in movies and the
the ultimate in his career was he was
nominated for an Oscar for a film called
Barton Fink amazing and Barton Fink he
plays the head of the capital Film
Studio there do we have a clip we do yes
here he is talking to Barton Fink played
by John Turturro the the new writer in
Hollywood off of his success in New York
and he's trying to get him to write a a
film a wrestling picture with Wallace
Berry in it and he's pitching it to uh
John in this scene
great work 81 years old great actor
[Applause]
he's like uh I've got uh he goes I've
got Horseheads God damn it Showmanship
oh my God I love that movie so much
folks happen uh things happen in TV and
films that aren't supposed to be seen by
the audience but we catch him here in
[__] that should not be
[Music]
here's some [__] that should not be
this one comes from Danny Collins from
Barnsley in the UK during season nine no
it's even worse now don't put
this will calm you down
vampire on that you were like
speaking of which man have you seen the
Renfield no I haven't I want to though
have you seen it not yet I was hoping
you did no I want to I like Nick Cage
when he's off the leash uh I agree I
don't mean to put your dick down but it
was in the way of seeing my friend yes
um Danny was watching friends and he
noticed you know a lot of people friends
is like a massive Resurgence a whole new
generation have discovered friends but
they're they're fine you know I've never
seen an episode get out yeah have you
every episode do you watch you you watch
I watched it the first time while it was
happening yes really
and then my kid fell in love with it my
13 year old daughter is now obsessed and
so we sit and we watch we binge friends
huh
it's friends I just I never [__] with
it wow yeah
it's 20 something is that right you
never saw it either
they have friends in Canada it's it's
it's a thing I'm from Canada I don't
know about the France they may not have
Aldi in Canada but they do have friends
yeah
it's it's young people sitting and
talking
it's your your kind of thing you would
like that I did that I know that's what
I'm saying it's right in your wheelhouse
yeah for some reason never ever never
fell down the friend hole
do they
do it's not good no no but still they
have one good to know anyway people are
watching it now because they're watching
it on uh you know on streaming service
stuff they're able to catch things they
couldn't catch the first time around and
so Danny noticed this uh with Jennifer
Aniston who apparently couldn't [__]
be bothered to do the scene with uh with
Matt LeBlanc here's a little piece of
video look look to the left if you can
commercials
to Matt LeBlanc can we still can we get
a shot of that John should we look who
the [__] is that girl standing next to
him oh [__] Jennifer Aniston couldn't be
asked to uh sit there and have someone
else have lines
there was a spin-off to that show after
it was Joey I was on that oh I bet you
watched Joey I watched my episode I bet
you did
but I remember I say ask me to like oh
we're your big friends fan I was like
what now oh no
and we also look out for acting in film
and television that is so bad it goes
all the way around to become Exquisite
acting
that is the question welcome to the
world of Exquisite acting with Ralph
Garman and Kevin Smith
uh usually we look at A-list actors who
have turned in d-list performances for
our fund for Exquisite acting but this
was so amazing this came from Max fawz
thank you Max uh this is from a film I
had never heard of until now called
Tammy and the T-Rex anybody know this
movie
the actors in the scene are Billy
Pilgrim and Siobhan Durkin the premise
of the film is
um it stars Paul Walker and Denise
Richards this is an actual movie uh Paul
Walker Paul Walker this is from 1994.
this film uh he dies and a mad scientist
puts his brain inside of an animatronic
T-Rex robot
that old story this is an episode of
Friends no
and so then uh he goes around to wreak
revenge against the high school students
who bullied him and to protect his
girlfriend Denise Richards
so in this scene he is going after Billy
the Kid who uh beat him up and caused
him to go into a coma and pass away and
uh Billy is with a girl in a car and
they're having sex and the reason I
picked these two actors this is a double
shot
um Billy Pilgrim and Siobhan Durkin are
the actors Siobhan Durkin has never had
sex before because she obviously doesn't
know how women react when they're having
sex and Billy admittedly has never seen
a giant robot Tyrannosaurus Rex before
but uh their reactions to everything in
this scene are just Exquisite it's a
minute of magic please enjoy
yes
yes yes
I'm good right
[Music]
here
now I want to see that movie so badly
now Tammy and the T-Rex sounds like
somebody had access to an animatronic
T-Rex like let's build the whole movie
around this
I'm not kidding you it's exactly what
[__] happened are you [__] me
there was a guy who built one and they
were shipping it to some theme park or
something and a guy had access to it for
a month and he said I'm gonna shoot a
movie based around a robot T-Rex that is
genius that's indie film right there
that's what came out was Tammy and the
T-Rex available everywhere right now
we love to take a look at all the
entertainment news as well here and
that's why we do the HBO headlines
[Music]
oh
Arnold Schwarzenegger is a man of action
okay that's all I have yeah
no he was in his neighborhood and there
was a bad pothole in the neighborhood
apparently was causing a lot of people
trouble with their uh with their cars
and their bikes and stuff I got a
pothole in my life yeah you do
so Arnold took it upon himself
to fill in the pothole himself I think
we have a picture of him actually doing
the road work there here he is holy [__]
he's uh putting in the uh the gravel and
then he put uh tar on top of it he's the
Terminator
Conan the Tiberian
you do prepare the show in advance
um how [__] awesome is that not
awesome at all yeah because it was
actually
service trench that so SoCal Gas Company
had dug because they were doing work in
the area and
so he wasn't
even so he was like [__] you
uh it turns out they were working in the
area they were digging a trench to get
access to the gas lines and he just
paved it over just filled it up
indeed yes and then insisted people take
photos as well ah look at me I'm the
deal digging in the covering things with
the Hop things
um yeah SoCal uh gas was like we were
working there Arnold and uh we know
you're a cinematic Legend but [__] off
so uh we don't try to do your job it was
uh the wrong hole
last time I filled around the hole it
cost me my marriage
wow
because of my Maids
I [__] my Maids
look at me I put this in the maid
the way you had to reach down for it you
can't get up it's like when you take a
leak with all this huge balls that's
right I gotta move them to the side
uh Arnold's good friend Sylvester
Stallone's in the news and if you saw
the new trailer that dropped this week
for the reality show the family Stallone
that's it's not a movie it's an actual
like they're doing the Kardashians they
are doing very much a Kardashians wow
this man is got like 86 daughters yes
and they are apparently holding him
hostage because I can only imagine
that's the only reason he would agree to
this it's going to be on Paramount plus
it uh debuts the 17th when is that uh
three days three days
um
it's it just looks awful
let's just show it just I got nothing
it's one of the world's biggest Stars
now see him like never before
as a family man
really
May 17th on Paramount plus I just jumped
or else you're downtown meet one
incredible family
I've always had this pressure of being
very perfect dating with the last name
that I have is incredibly hard being a
Stallone it holds a lot of weight
my sister and I run a podcast called
unwaxed
it doesn't get much better than this
brainwise body wise looks wise we're at
our Peak ladies all right let's keep
going when I was younger I fell in love
with acting what happened
I am so nervous walking onto that set
don't screw this up Scarlett love you
family is everything so we're all
together it feels like home I know we're
insane I know we're crazy but we love
each other so much
I can't believe you guys are actually
doing a reality show I would have
thought you on TV like this you're
welcome
[Music]
not how hard you hit it's about hard you
can get hit and keep moving forward
we're Stallone we can keep it together
we're always we're gonna have each
other's back
it's quite ironic that he's the last
person that wanted to do this reality
show yet he sees the camera and he's
like
am I in French that's the truth the
family's still alone and all new reality
series streaming May 17th exclusively on
Paramount plus that's a good dad right
there that is Dad of the [__] year
really truly [__] there's his yoga
hosers moment right there
that's this one of the saddest things
I've ever seen no that's sweet
that's sweet what do you think he is now
um 11d
I just turned 11 years old
and you know so like my my wife is like
100 years younger than me and then the
kids are like 120 years younger than me
so I had to like do something because
you know divorce was on the horizon yeah
remember that there was a moment where
they were about to split up yeah I think
they got back together again so the show
would work quite frankly what do you
think the botox budget is on that set
for that entire family including Sly he
uh he he looks like uh he's like you
know how to [__] Keanu Reeves took
all the dialogue out of John Wick and
he's got like 13 lines in the whole
movie yes he's like the John Wick of the
show hey look at me I'm like I'm like
brushing a [__] okay
so that's like good right that'll be a
good shot like meow you know and then
I'm like what
the tail
huh
so sad will you watch yeah yeah
speaking of the Kardashian
Ash during the cast of American Horror
Story
how can you tell the difference between
that and her family that's what I would
like to know
season 12. has she ever acted before oh
well she's been in things
I don't know if if you could call
anything that she's done acting but yeah
she has she was in the uh
something she did something she did that
but she was also in some features in the
in a couple things too anyway I just if
they murder her I'll watch but other
than that I'm not interested it's a
horror show she could get killed right
there's no blue there's hope she could
be like Drew Barrymore in the first
scream like they could take her out in
the first few minutes oh that'd be so
hot
I wouldn't have to watch anymore I could
just watch that first episode and you
can turn over to the family Stallone
yeah so like I can't believe you're
doing this show hi everybody
it's me Sly the Pacino's in it too do
you see that in the clip that was I look
like I'm in Stallone world now
don't how how big are their house
payments all these guys they had to take
every job if if my [__] kid talked me
into doing a reality show you wouldn't
do it with me
if you asked me I would do it I would
make you [__] brush a cat
just so you'd eat your [__] words
still a little bit of hoes you feel yeah
it's not so funny now is it it's not
about a heart a life hits you it's about
how you can get up again and keep moving
forward after you brush the cat down
[Applause]
uh reboots remakes uh we don't [__]
need them we've already got him
[Music]
another one it's already been done I
haven't heard that theme song dusting
off some of the classics that goes
pre-pandemic that one
um HBO Max now known just as Max
yeah how that was kind of Dopey no it's
stupid yeah yeah because the HBO part is
the part people The Classy part though
it's not the max part no Max was
Jonathan Hart's assistant on Heart to
Heart
wow
old man that's what I think
when they met it was murder
this is Mr H I think it's Cinemax yeah
or skidamax so it sounds like a porn
[__] joke but now that they're not
using anymore Hollywood Babylon HBO we
can call ourselves HBO Max
oh my God they're not using it anymore
that's the name of our reality show with
our daughters that's right
uh they have announced they are going to
put together a Harry Potter television
series based on the popular books this
yeah nothing lasts forever anymore I
honestly thought that was like Daniel
Radcliffe and all those Potter kids
would be those characters until they
[__] died but now they thought Harry
Potter Wizard of Oz for generations to
come like every generation would watch
that growing up but they're like nah
[__] that we're gonna do it all over
again on Max nothing matters anymore
that's the problem it's like it used to
used to wait for a thing right how many
years did you wait for a [__] Potter
movie between those when they were doing
book by book by book yeah and now it's
just so disposable it's like let's just
do it again and and I know they've been
doing that for years they did it with
James Bond they've done it with Batman
they've been several Batman there's been
several Spider-Man as well but this felt
[__] special but they didn't remake
Goldfinger 20 times
you know they wrote they wrote new
scripts this is the Harry Potter books
that they did the movies on are now
going to be a TV series and it's a deal
that they made for 10 years by the way
it's going to be a 10 a decade how do
you I know the kids are supposed to age
like in the books they go through school
but it's only like four years that
they're in school right there's seven
books but four years they take place
over yes so seven years another seven
books but it technically isn't seven
years right it's the four years is it
seven years
all right so you gotta get some kids but
it's magic so it's like four years
off to all of you who knew it was seven
years [__] nerds
and I say that with the utmost respect
um you gotta get some [__] sperm and
shoot the show with them man because
it's gonna take you 20 years to shoot 10
seasons those kids are going into a
[__] uh cement building and not
coming out for [__] seven years
they're gonna miss their entire [__]
job between Seasons I heard they said it
on the when they announced the show
they're gonna put them in a cryogenic
chamber to try to slow down their
maturation and growth by freezing them
to almost uh perfect zero I don't think
they can have between Seasons I think
they just have to shoot
before those kids age wow clerks TV show
they tried that yeah yeah yeah yeah they
did
uh and also are we talking about remix
Baywatch Baywatch is coming back that
makes sense why
why Beach wearing bikinis and [__] you
can get away with it that was the 80 s
when I couldn't jerk off to my phone
but we don't need this now I don't need
a number of baywatches haven't they yes
and they all were [__] and now it's
going to be [__] new [__] they should
combine Potter and Baywatch together pod
watch
not anymore
and uh gay Justin Bieber's in the news
what do you know
why
I'll tell you why
that's right it does my heart good I
haven't heard that in a while uh Justin
Bieber you know he uh he canceled his
whole tour or post postponed it
postponed it at least seems like he does
that quite a bit yeah he does he doesn't
he doesn't really want to sing so much
anymore he's got a lot of other things
he likes to do like the thing this
story's about he is struggling with his
fashion line
uh Drew house is the name of his fashion
line he launched it and sunk about 20
million dollars into it and apparently
it's not doing very well at all I can't
believe no one wants to buy a 150 hoodie
with a smiley face on it but oh he did
that kind of thing here's uh here's his
fashion line and see if you can figure
out why no one's buying this [__]
why'd you is that Justin Bieber these
days yes he looks like a father I took
that picture behind Flappers here by the
dumpster
all of his fashion has smiley faces on
it the only thing Justin Bieber doesn't
do anymore is smile yeah Drew's his
middle name and that's why he called him
I was wondering why and uh apparently
it's a failure and it's bleeding money
and he is uh he's Furious and he's he's
considering just stopping music and
going full time into fashion to bring
his fashion brand back to life he just
can't believe it oh my God
file I will I will file that one
let's take a look at some geek news
[Music]
what's up uh Star Wars celebration was
last weekend
our friend JC went over there he went to
England yeah he was there for it that's
love yeah at first I got like kind of
tight about it where I was like why are
they doing it in England man what about
America and then they were like they
shot him in England I was like oh yeah
oh yeah
um they've announced of course uh Ahsoka
the new live-action Star Wars series
which is amazing with Rosario Dawson so
good in that man that whole trailer
looks really great uh this Dave filoni
he seems like he knows what he's doing
doesn't he he's the real deal man I went
and did I forget who I was doing it for
but maybe it's tonight's show or
something but we went to Skywalker once
and um I was uh interviewing people and
stuff and I got to talk to Dave this was
going years back wait he was doing the
animated stuff probably when he was
working on even pre-rebels even and
stuff and um I think like you know it
was I was making [__] prequel jokes
as you did back in those days jar jar
jokes and [__] and he got real like
serious where he was like you don't
understand those movies they're really
good and he gave me like a 20 minute
break down to those of the prequels that
really spun me around I went home
watched him I was like he's right these
are [__] good wow yeah he's devoted
man he's he's true uh died in the wall
like lucasfan and believe me
it's him and Fabs like have you been
watching uh Mandalorian I have I'm a
couple episodes behind but the [__]
episode this week is fantastic I can't
wait really fantastic it's good stuff I
remember when it first came out and I
sort of laughed at it you're like you
have to watch it yeah it's like Kung Fu
with Star Wars you'll love it
they uh you know they got some [__] this
season from people that thought they
like lost their way or didn't do enough
Mandalorian episodes but I actually
didn't mind the episodes where they
stepped away from Mandalorian they're
just one episode with like Dr Pershing
that character did you see that no one
not yet it's [__] dope where they do
this whole mythology oh yeah where he's
sort of uh he's he's been peeled off in
the amnesty program he's been
restructured in the idea of like
Imperials who like after after Return of
the Jedi got a bunch of Imperials who
were like well I you know I was just
following orders and [__] and so they
bring them into the new Republic and
they recondition them and try to like
make them part of society while still
keep them separate like those are
Imperials and [__] right but it was
really like an interesting episode and
kind of kind of cool like the twists and
turns that it took but the most recent
episode is like all Mandalorian and and
and there you know now they're
questioning like what is that title mean
because it's not necessarily just about
din jar and the one Mandalorian right we
got Boca Raton Florida too
that's right yeah Boca Raton
they've rewarded Dave filoni by giving
him a movie he's going to be doing one
of the Star Wars
this is going to wrap up all that stuff
yeah in a feature film so we're going to
see baby uh Yoda grogu on the big screen
man finally can't get enough of him
for one of my favorite moments on this
show pull it bop it pull it bop it pull
it pop it pull it pull it pull it
one of my favorite moments on the show
where it was actually during a very sad
time in your life yes when uh it was
your was it your mom my father just
passed yeah and I was in the midst of a
divorce and he was in the midst of
divorce and he was like talking about it
on the show and I was like oh my God
have you seen the Mandalorian yet like
it's amazing show you got to watch it he
was just like I'm going through the
worst time in my life I got time for
baby Yoda and [__] so my father just
died I have time for [__] baby Yoda
yeah whatever yeah
I'll keep you up to date all the deaths
my relatives you'll have a laugh Riot
it'll be a good time for you
that was good man [__] where'd you pull
that from
Star Wars
it's from Star Wars Kevin
okay everybody
hey when are we gonna see wrong reasons
why can I see wrong reasons why can't I
where can I see that movie August 15th
on Blu-ray DVD and streaming what August
15th everyone can see the film that Josh
wrote and directed and uh
some of the best actors I've ever seen
that's all I know that's all I know
who's in it
what's that Kevin Smith's in it he is he
is in that uh yeah Josh gave me a big
juicy role and it was so much fun to do
so I act with my mouth which is
something I never normally do right you
have to speak words and everything I
said some [__] you did Not So Silent Bob
you acted with your mouth but you always
do that well not in your films yeah
one [__] time man yoga she said a lot
of [__] you saw what happened there so
next next time you go back to saying
nothing
um and lastly the Marvel's trailer
dropped this week have you seen this
from mom I mean I hesitate to say it out
loud Because the Internet will [__]
circumcise me this year but I thought it
was great I did too it's great right and
I was shocked how
excited and interested in I'm in seeing
this film yeah because I I don't be
wrong I like Captain Marvel and I like I
don't know what Brie Larson billion
people some people really don't like her
but I think she's fine I think she's I
didn't watch the Ms Marvel show on
Disney plus I just I just didn't get
around to it it's wonderful I've heard
it's great and the the filmmakers behind
the show are absolutely legit like the
style of that show is great she is
charming as hell but that was a legit
great show I enjoyed it uh the character
of Monica Rambo she was on uh one
division which I also [__] loved so
now they're bringing them together into
this Trio of female superheroes called
the Marvels and I I went in going and I
saw the trailer and I was blown away I
thought it was fun as fun as the
internet took a big [__] in its mouth
did it really and it wasn't aware God
they're going like oh it's [__] one
of them fun movies it's like yeah I'm
sorry God forbid I mean that's the thing
to keep going like why can't Marvel go
back to being serious what was the
serious movie other than Captain America
uh like the Winter Soldier like and
everything has always had some levity to
it yeah some Joy but people act like
[__] no no no [__] they're taking
it too funny now but there's always been
like elements of humor in all those
movies should we watch the trailer
together and we'll decide in the room
yes hit it Josh
foreign
what the hell are you doing
entering the jump Point perimeter
I'm gonna get you some readings Fury
hello hello
[Music]
[Applause]
is this an Avenger
where's Captain Rambo
[Music]
what the hell
we're looking for kamalakon
okay so our powers are entangled I can
manipulate light energy and you I could
totally show you
again
hi where's our daughter Wherever You Are
[Music]
working
we're a team oh no no no we're not we're
not a team
[Music]
I'm gonna look great man
I have to say Brie Larson though was the
thing that broke the internet this week
the shot of her apparently the whole
internet even though a lot of people on
the internet don't seem to like her come
out against her whatever that shot of
her in the white top in the crop top yes
that was it that was a thumbs up from
the internet like even people like I
hate her but I love that shot like they
really went for it and I like boobs yes
she talked about how because people were
like those are that's some
gravity-defined [__] bra work right
there and she said that it was a whole
team that worked on it and there's a
third strap on the bra that's crazy
that's why it works and stuff I just
read a whole article about it
thank you
I read it very slowly
yes
[Laughter]
she's from New Jersey Bree is yeah
all right
you know what they have in New Jersey
Aldi
stop it
the more you know I have to say though
selfishly as the father of a 13 year old
girl I don't hate that there's a movie
for her where it's a bunch of girls
kicking ass and fighting super hey I
agree with you B don't say that out loud
I know I'm sorry I apologize it's just
for boys sorry I don't know what I was
thinking all right kids it's time for us
to say goodbye but before we do
wait before we [__] go what you make
me smell lavender again no uh one more
reminder uh when do we do this again
we'll be back here next month on the
20th of May y'all gonna come back come
on back come back and join us except
Norway in Australia you guys no they
have to come too yeah
and then uh and then New Jersey the
third year third and fourth come see us
in New Jersey it's mod Castle man
because that Super Mario Brothers movie
ain't gonna be around it's not working
yeah
and we're literally we're going to try
to do it uh monthly moving on from here
on out to uh get on a more regular
schedule because some people are like
what are you guys going to do another
Hollywood
picked on like four recently
[__] but nobody knows we could
take him on the road to Places You'll
never remember like Reno Nevada that's
right
back there I enjoyed that show that was
really fun that was our
time
dick shooter Idaho we're going to dick
shooter because um y'all dick shooter
shoot your dick in my direction
that's not how that went was that
Apollonia yeah yeah but vanity six
vanity six that's right [__] call I
wish I had more manscape things to give
you for that answer absolutely I don't
boy we say goodbye though that we have
one last bit of business we always like
to tell the facts of Liam Neeson one of
the biggest [__] in Show Business and I
mean that in a good way
you almost knocked my drink over with
your [__] story of my life he is a
famously one of the biggest penises in
Hollywood every week you folks send in
your stuff to HBO podcast at AOL.com to
give us your facts you can email us by
the way at that email address for
anything you'd like to send our way here
they are this week's facts about Liam
Neeson's [__]
[Music]
you could be a muppeteer I learned from
the back that's right
Liam Neeson's [__] is so big how big is
it the U.S attempted to shoot it down
thinking it was a spy balloon
true
Liam Neeson [__] is so big how big is it
Liam unzipped and left a crater that
Arnold Schwarzenegger had to fill
Ed
him it's girth makes Brendan Fraser in
the well look like Karen Carpenter
too soon too soon for Karen Carpenter
jokes I can't believe people got that
joke
it's like referencing Heart to Heart
when they met it was murder
Liam Neeson's [__] is so big
his orgasm resulted in a Multiverse that
only the flash can repair
yeah and lastly Liam neese's [__] is so
big
it's getting its own biopic entitled
everything everywhere all at once
ladies and gentlemen if you had a good
time this evening
thank you so much for joining us we
truly appreciate you being here very
much there is no show without the man in
my left give it up for Ralph [__]
Garmin
let's hear it for my bestest buddy and
Babel brother Mr Kevin Smith
and that is Hollywood Babylon for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Rob Carman bad
[__] good night
[Music]
give it up for Ralph Garmin and Kevin
Smith
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old I'm Kevin
Smith
thank you